a 14 year old boy has shot his teacher
and eight other students in central
Belgrade a security guard was also shot
Serbian police say the suspect has been
arrested adding that he had used his
father's gun mass shootings are rare in
Serbia which has strict gun laws let's
go live to Al jazeera's ognan zores
joining us from Belgrade so what more
are we learning about this incident
well I'll say first that what we are
witnessing since this morning are many
people that are shocked and in tears
here around the school mostly pupils
from this school that have been
evacuated uh this morning but also their
parents who are trying to comfort them
at also the citizens of Belgrade that
are in Shock after this tragedy that's
not common in these areas so it
Disturbed very uh whole Serbia but also
the region what you can see behind me is
that the streets in this area are still
closed there are many many police
officers that are investigating uh all
the details of this tragedy but also the
motives that led to it what we know so
far is that shooter that suspect for
shooting was a 14-year old boy the
student of the is school police
confirmed earlier that eight students
have been killed and also one security
guard while six other people five
students among them and one teacher are
still in hospital where doctors are
taking care taking care of them
president of municipality of Racha
that's the municipality for this school
is located told us earlier that based on
video surveillance in this school they
can tell that shooting started this
morning
in the hallway of the school the
security guard was first that saw the
shooter so he tried to stop him and lost
his life doing it after that the shooter
turned his gun to over the other
students that were in a hallway
and he was arrested some a couple of
hours ago in in a in a schoolyard right
and as you say as you say okay I mean
this is this is very rare In This Moment
yeah and as you've been saying I mean
this this is very rare to have to yes
happen in Belgrade so tell us a little
bit about the reaction of the people
that you've been speaking to this is
very rare the mass shootings are very
rare right
uh yes um uh that that's the reason that
they are shocked because mass shootings
are rare and this is the first time in
Serbia that this tragedy like this is
happening in a school that children are
involved this uh suspect was suspected
to use his father's gun that he brought
up to school in the backpack and we are
coming to that that this is rare that's
the reason why school uh wasn't uh using
the metal detectors on their doors so
now we are speaking about that our uh is
some more security measures needed so
many many uh unions of the of the people
that work in the school uh stopped uh
closed the schools for today all the
schools in Serbia and they say that
schools weren't working uh even tomorrow
until they are sure that every school
School in Serbia is safe after this
tragedy Oakland zorich thank you for
that update from Belgrade